before
i talk to you about love let me ask you
a difficult question you write in your
book
i don't consider myself much of a
criminal i don't lie
cheat or steal and i always take up for
the underdog
violence makes me sick yet i know i'm an
outlaw
and those that break the law must be
punished
i think many people listening to this or
some people listening to this
will see you as a criminal as a bad man
who increased the amount of suffering in
this world
what do you have to say to them
i would like to tell them that they have
been indoctrinated by the spin
of news and politicians and they don't
know the truth of the situation
you lay the truth out there in an
envelope let me open it
besides something else that is false and
it's staggering
the truth is that i was a tobacco farmer
and tobacco kills 500 000 people a year
in america
and 6 million have a debilitating
diseases because of it
drugs all drugs combined kill between 10
and 15
000 people a year by overdose and 60
percent of those are pharmaceutical
now that when i was a tobacco farmer
come sit on the front pew mr reeves come
on up here you a gentleman
you just joined the masonic lodge and
you joined our church
and you just come on and sit down with
the good people you grow two marijuana
plants
get out of here you scumbag and
marijuana doesn't hurt anybody
it's just that's the truth of it
and so in your career
you were you walked amidst violence
but you never participated in the
violence i didn't even see it
just didn't happen around me in prison
it did i sewed people up they called me
doc i
had dental floss and uh uh
one one time i had to get a blade and
try to help keep them from my patient
from getting again but i don't was just
like if i shot at those people i shot
them to keep them from killing me
i certainly didn't mean to kill them
so that's just some people are evil and
they will kill you and hurt you and lie
to you
i just don't do any of that it's just it
just makes you sick
i've seen it i was when i was in the
shoe three guys tried to kill a guy and
they stabbed him so many times but
their stab went breaking the blood
getting out of the room and actually
going to kill him you're going to kill
him
and save his life drug him up there
where the guards could see him
there's stuff like that i'm just not of
that nature of those people they're just
evil
there's people born evil i believe yeah
it is heartbreaking to hear that the
basic humanity's gone in prison
in the united states that's
heartbreaking because that basic
humanity
is actually the light at the end of the
tunnel it's the thing that saves us
as opposed to when it's absent it's the
thing that destroys us
the prisoners are filled absolutely
filled with people
that have some mental problems
now you see tent city all the way up and
down here i guarantee you every one of
those
people have mental problems some degree
however little it is but they're a
little bit off now then you get a dea
agent
that wants to make a name for himself he
goes down there and gets two of them
one of them to sell a little two grams
of methamphetamine to the other one
and he gets a conviction and a young
prosecutor he gets a conviction he wants
to make a judge
and we got to judge and where was it i'm
gonna give him a million
what's his name gilbert i'm gonna make
i'm going to give me a million years
before i get off the judge
you get fools like that in charge
you're going to fill prisons up with
pitiful humanity and those are the ones
and then the other
is people over drugs
and drugs should be a uh a health issue
you can't you cannot
police it enough it's just they know
like the only thing that overdoses
is opioids the heroin and if they can
give it to them it costs about a dollar
a day to give the worst addict
is his fix but they'll give it methadone
which is from a pharmaceutical company
which is just as bad
why in the world we tried it all over
the world
in portugal and england and when they
give the
the girls cleanup no more stolen cars
why who who wants to keep this forest
going
they just perpetuating it like oh every
little
police place is getting all these suits
and armor and machine guns
it's just like oh it's it's such a spin
it's
sad do you think all drugs should be
legalized
i don't know about that but they
certainly should be controlled if a
person is an addict
he should be able to go down and get his
fix with somebody there to help him with
a clean needle
and a glass of orange juice it's so much
cheaper
than prison so much cheaper than him
stealing cars
or prostitute having to go to work
that's sad
you